IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME, WHY
WOULD MAKE THAT?
WHY WOULD YOU MAKE THAT?
SOME WEB SITES ARE SO SEEMINGLY
POINTLESS THAT THEIR VERY
EXISTENCE BOGGLES THE MIND.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU TWO OPTIONS
FOR ULTRA-BIZARRE SINGLE-SERVING
WEB SITES AND FOR 250 POINTS YOU
TELL ME WHICH ONE IS REAL.
FIRST ONE, EELSLAP.COM-- WATCH A
MAN GET SLAPPED WITH AN EEL-- OR
SEAURCHINPURGE.COM-- WATCH A
MIDDLE-AGED WOMAN VOMIT ON A SEA
URCHIN.
(BELL DINGS)
I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE IS REAL,
BUT I'M SURE EITHER ONE OF THEM
ARE IN JAPAN.
HEATHER.
>> I'M PRAYING FOR EELSLAP.COM.
>> HARDWICK: HOW MANY TIMES HAVE
YOU SAID THAT THIS WEEK?
>> FOUR.
>> HARDWICK: FOUR TIMES.
ALL RIGHT, THE CORRECT ANSWER
IS...
EEL SLAP!
>> YES!
>> HARDWICK: EEL SLAP.
OH, MY GOD, GAIJIN, I DIDN'T
KNOW, IT'S NOT JAPAN AT ALL.
WHAT-WHAT...
WAY TO PICK UP THE SLACK, WHITE
PEOPLE.
NEXT ONE, PRO-CAT-INATOR-- A
RANDOM CAT GIF IS PAIRED WITH A
RANDOM SONG-- OR
THEEMPIRESTRIKESBARK-- VIDEOS
OF PUPPIES OVERDUBBED WITH LINES
FROM STAR WARS.
OH, GOD DAMN IT.
UH...
NICK.
>> I'M GONNA GO WITH
THEEMPIRESTRIKESBARK, CHRIS,
THANK YOU.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, NICK, UH, THE MOST
VALUABLE LESSON YOU CAN LEARN
ABOUT THE INTERNET IS WHEN IN
DOUBT, IT'S ALWAYS CATS.
PRO-CAT-INATOR.
♪ ♪
OH, I WANTED MORE.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> THERE'S... THEY SUPER GLUE
THEM TO THE FLOOR TO GET THEM TO
DO THAT.
>> HARDWICK: THEY CALL THIS...
>> THEY'RE DEAD, THERE ARE JUST
PEOPLE BEHIND THEM...